صارت الصين هي المتحكمة في كل
شيء. وهذا لم ياتي من فراغ بل
لا تحتاج اليه في فرض سيطرة
ونفوذها. فقوة اصحاب العيون
السياسيين على مستوى العالم.
النابغين في العلوم الهندسية
وانظمة تسليم لهذه ولهذا تعد قوة
عسكرية اقليمية كبرى وقوة عسكرية
تعدت الشبال الشاهقة. ركزت الصين
على التجارة بوصفها وسيلة رئيسية
الملايين من الصينيين للجوع
والسلب والذبح. بعد ان نهبت
ولهذا تعمل الصين على اقامة
علاقات عسكرية خارجية. وبرغم
العظمى في العالم اقتصاديا
وسياسيا وعسكريا. فالعمل بصمت هو
اقوى ميزات الصين. سيصحو العالم
يوما وفي مقدمتهم امريكا. وقد
الضيقة تأتي من قوة الاقتصاد
والتجارة التي استطاعت بها ان
ظل وجود اثنين فاصل خمسة مليون
جندي في الخدمة. فان جيش التحرير
ذلك الهدف. تكامل بين الشعب
وحكومته. قوة التنين الصيني. في
الشعبي الصيني هو الاضخم في
العالم. تمتلك الصين اسلحة نووية
تزداد شهرا بعد شهر. وعاما بعد
اخر. حتى تصبح الصين هي القوة
اضغاث احلام للشعب الصيني الذي
كان يريد التحرر من تخلف دون
جدوى. بل كانت ارادة نظام خطط
بحكمة وصبر وايمان شعب تناغم مع
العالم. حيث تعد الصين اكبر وجهة
للصادرات لثلاثة وثلاثين دولة.
تسيطر على العالم. فصناعة الصين
في كل منزل في العالم والتجارة
الامن. التي تمتلك قدرة محدودة
في مجال قذف القوة العسكرية.
عظمى صاعدة. والصين هي الدولة
الوحيدة الدائمة العضوية في مجلس
في السنوات التي تلت ذلك. وبلغ
متوسط حوالي عشرة بالمائة. تسارع
القوة العظمى التي تتمتع بها
الصين في السلاح والجيش. لكنها
نهضة الصين مجرد صدفة حضارية في
بلد غني بالموارد. ولم تكن مجرد
والاقتصادية والادارة. وتعليمهم
كان بصفة رئيسية في العالم
عام الفين وواحد. في تعزيز
باعتبارها مصنعا واكبر تاجر في
السبعينيات. بدأت الصين سلسلة من
الاصلاحات في عام الف وتسعمائة
الطريق نحو القمة. حيث الغت
الحكومة الشيوعية امتيازات
اتبعها. حيث بدأ في اواخر
السبعينيات والثمانينيات من
في الاقتصاد والصناعة في الصين
الشعبية. يعود الى السياسة التي
الغربي. كذلك ساعد انضمام الصين
الى منظمة التجارة العالمية في
واكبر مصدر للواردات لخمسة وستين
دولة عن اي تجارة نتحدث. لم تكن
غير الكفأة. فالشعب الصيني لا
يلعب في عمله. هذا النمو السريع
الهندسة والاقتصاد وطرق الادارة
الحديثة. بغرض التطوير الاقتصادي
القرن الماضي في ارسال البعثات
الى البلاد الغربية لتعلم
للنمو. اغلقت الشركات غير
المربحة. واجرت هيكلة للشركات
من نوع اخر بين الحكومة الصينية
وميليشيات الحزب الشيوعي. وانتهى
العظمة. ما لم يخض صعوبات وكوارث
كهذه. بعد اندلاع الحرب الصينية
ذات سيادة. وهنا كانت بداية
التغيير يا سادة حزم وقوة في
اليابانية الثانية في الفترة ما
بين عامي الف وتسعمائة وسبعة
وثلاثين والف وتسعمائة وخمسة
واربعين. وبهزيمة الصين بدأ صراع
دولار تعد الصين ثاني اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم لكن مهلا فهذا
في البلاد. واصبحت المجموعة
الحاكمة معظمها حاليا من اكثر
للحزب الشيوعي على الحكم. واعلان
موت سيتونج قيام جمهورية الصين
الشعبية. وصنعت الصين استراتيجية
القفزة الكبرى. ويا لها من قفزة
رهيب. لن تراه الا في بلاد
المليار نسمة يا عزيزي. ومع
بابتسامة عريضة ستقول شكرا ايها
الصينيون. شكرا يا اصحاب العيون
الصينية الحديثة. وشرع القادة
الجدد في اعادة بناء اقتصاد
عام الف وتسعمائة وتسعة واربعين
بسيطرة الجيش الاحمر التابع
القوات الغربية واليابان
اقتصادها. فلا يصل احد الى هذه
الشيوعية في منتصف القرن
العشرين. التي صاغت الدولة
وثمانية وسبعين. اخرجت البلاد من
عزلتها الاقتصادية. وتسارع النمو
النساء والمخدرات. تحت قيادة احد
ابرز واقوى قادة البلاد في
وباجمالي الناتج محلي يبلغ اربعة
عشر فاصل اربعة عشر تريليون
ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
ممكنا سوى باندلاع الثورة
هو الواقع اليوم. اما من قبل فلم
يكن صعود الصين الحديثة لتصبح
يقول المحللون وتعتلي الصين قمة
الاقتصاد العالمي؟ مزيحة
الغزو الامبراطوري الياباني. لم
تعد دولة موحدة. وتعرض مئات
الحرب. وطردت اصحاب الملايين من
ملاك بيوت الدعارة. وتجارة
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية من
التخبط الى الاستقرار والعظمة.
المستعمرين الغربيين. وانهت
الاقطاعيات الاقليمية لامراء
الهول الحقيقي من قبل. وهكذا لا
احد تثيره الدهشة والغرابة. اذا
الياباني الغازي. مما سمح اعادة
توحيد الصين لتصبح دولة مستقلة
البداية هزم جيش التحرير الشعبي
الاحمر الجيش الامبراطوري
واليابانيون. يا لها من حياة
بائسة عاشها الصينيون حينها. في
دمرته الحروب الامبراطورية.
ونهبه الرأس الماليون الغربيون
رأى يوما جميع حضارات العالم
موجودة في الصين. اذا ذهبت الى
لم تسرق التمثال ولم تشتره.
وانما سرقت معالمه وصنعت نسخة
الضيقة. ماذا لو ان اعينهم اوسع
قليلا. بهذه الطريقة وهذه السرقة
وبعشرة دولارات فقط. عادت
الابتسامة الى محياك الان. سنة.
يا الهي. هنا تعبس بوجهك وترى ان
نقودك لا تكفي. فتحاول ترك
القطعة ليرد عليك البائع مهلا.
انتظر فلدينا نسخة صينية منها
وهذه الخطط الشيطانية وهذا
الابداع. ما هي الا سنوات كما
المعالم التاريخية في العالم منذ
الاف السنين. يأتي السياح
واقوى الاسلحة. ان تستطيع سرقة
سلاح او بالاحرى القدرة على
لنفسها ايضا. وهنا قد استنسخت
اقوى الطائرات الحربية الامريكية
منه. واستطاعت ان تروج له في
العالم. ليحقق دخلا لم يحققه ابو
البائع وطلبت منه صنفا او قطعة
محلية واخبرك انها بمائة دولار
استنساخ سلاح فذلك شيء لكن الصين
اتجهت الى ما هو اعظم. لقد
استنسخت السياحة. ماذا? نعم هو
ما سمعتم. لكن كيف? كيف تستطيع
لرؤيتها من جميع ارجاء المعمورة.
وذات يوم لم المصريون الا وقد تم
نقل تمثال ابو الهول المشهور الى
الصين. لكن كيف ذلك? مهلا. الصين
دولة ان تستنسخ السياحة? في مصر
هناك الاهرامات وهي احدى اشهر
باقي الصناعات. الصين لا تصنع
لكي يستفيد العالم فقط بل تصنع
مماثلا للصناعات الامريكية لكن
بايدي صينية. في الصين ليس هناك
من اي شيء. وسيصنعون منه
الملايين والمليارات. الصين تصنع
معظم دول العالم على الصناعة
الصينية فهي متوفرة وبسعر اقل عن
كل شيء تقريبا على هذا الكوكب من
وحتى اضخم الالات العصرية. تعيش
اختراعا صينيا. فيكفي فقط ان
يأخذ اصحاب العيون الضيقة نسخة
شيء لا يستطيعون الصينيون
صناعته. وليس شرطا ان يكون
الطنين الصيني الى هذه القوة غير
المسبوقة هي السرقة او ما تسمى
تخشى ان تعرض صناعاتها العسكرية
منها. خوفا ان تصنع الصين شيئا
بعملية الاستنساخ. حتى ان
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية باتت
الصينيين ويراه العالم حقيقة؟
كيف وضع الصين قواعد السيطرة على
دون اعتراض احد. السرقة في
العالم. احد اهم اسباب وصول
العالم؟ كيف انتقلت من الفقر الى
امبراطورية اقتصاد. كيف اصبحت
دولة عظيمة؟ وكيف تسرق الصين
العالم ويصبح ما سرقوه حلالا لهم
وترضخ لايرادات القوى العظمى فعن
اي مجد نتحدث؟ وعن اي حلم يراود
تهزمها بريطانيا ويعبث بها الغرب
وتغزوها روسيا واليابان من مرة
هل كانت الامة الصينية عظيمة
حقا؟ الم تكن الصين بقعة جغرافية
العيون الضيقة والنظرة الثاقبة.
من الحضيض الى القمة. ومن الذل
الى السيطرة. الامبراطورية التي
تخطط لحكم العالم من مكانها. لكن
العالم يمشي وباتجاه الصين مقدما
امواله دون ان يشعر. اصحاب
بجهد جهيد من امبراطورية الصين
العظيمة.
سنأخذ كل ما في جيوبكم. قالها
الصينيون بسخرية للعالم. وها هو